more than 300 000 people in Morocco have
been affected by the earthquake a week
ago that's according to the United
Nations nearly 3 000 people were killed
and cleanup operations are still
underway Villages and towns in the
Hiatus mountains are among the hardest
hit
reports from where guns south of
Marrakesh with the aid effort is ramping
up
this is the airflow that has been used
by the jundameri over the last few days
it's been the focal point of the
emergency response operation that has
been going non-stop since the aftermath
of the earthquake this helicopter is
going to take us we're going to fly with
this crew all the way to some areas and
this is the pilot which is going to give
us some a few details about what is
going to happen good morning good to see
you good to talk to you can you give us
a sense of what is happening our mission
is a transporting generators and a
medical team on this helicopter a super
Puma of a royal John darmory we will
take off from where again and we will
fly over the whole devastated area to
the Village which is a very remote and
we will be on board with you thank you
very much
this is the Operation Center atop John
darmory General is over here these are
the generation as we are going to be
taken over to the affected area Syria
the biggest challenge which is going to
be over the upcoming days is the weather
and this explains why we because when we
were driving to this Airfield it was
basically the biggest challenge was
basically the need to deliver more and
more Aid to the affected areas because
with the makeshift comes with all the
installations put into place you have to
brace yourself for what could be a
prolonged cold weather in the upcoming
days there are Medical Teams over here
ready to fly over the area and this is
you can see behind me more helicopters
which are going to be part of the
Airfield which continues all the way
below you can see the town of vergan
where we're reporting live over the last
few days dotted with tense makeshift
camps all the way and the Ravine which
serpentines its way through the
mountains is where you have the most
effective areas
in the Atlas Mountains
let's bring in another one of our
correspondents Stephanie Decker she's
joining us live from aduz in the Atlas
Mountains and that is one of the hardest
hit areas Stephanie I know that you've
been watching villagers go through the
rubble of their homes by hand what do
these people do now
well that's the big question I think we
all know the feeling of going through
our front doors and feeling wherever
we've come from finally say if you close
that front door and you're at home well
this is uh what's left of at least one
home here many of them have been
pulverized nothing remains at all uh you
did say we're in the village of aduz the
first Village we came to about a week
ago was in mentala which is across the
way
um you see how the mountain there just
gave way
um the entire Village is destroyed at
that time we couldn't get to where we
are now because
um because of the roads a lot of heavy
Rock fall from um from the earthquake
that really Disturbed the mountain we're
gonna just take you a small walk to give
you a sense of what's happened to
people's lives here electricity cables
hanging low
um
it's complete rubble and yes you
mentioned there we've been seeing some
villagers come back
um
going through time
picking up items
prey we're just going to take you
through
that
I apologize for that bad connection with
our correspondent Stephanie Decker she
is in the Atlas Mountains let's go to
her report
we've come to a different location today
this is the town of mulai
it is easier to get to there's more
infrastructure around here very much
also a tourist place where tourists come
we're trying to figure out what the
situation is like here we bumped into
this uh gentleman David
yes
okay we're going to uh see a friend of
his who was with him David was here the
night of the earthquake on Friday night
and he says he hasn't heard from his
friend he's not answering his phone
so this town is uh much more established
than the other very remote Villages
we've been to but the structure here
also
on a very large scale
how much of the town has been damaged
they say about it
maybe
more than 50 percent
completely destroyed
see it's minaret in cracks and again
here just goes to show again the
challenge of
um bringing heavy equipment into these
areas removing all this and rebuilding
that is
the main challenge really everywhere
yeah we'll go before you'll find
his friend is home and fine next time
answer your phone he tells him don't
make me worry
we've been traveling through the
mountains this past week through
Villages more remote less remote
and everything we see raises the
question just how difficult it's going
to be
to access these places clear it
and then rebuild
ing
how are you coping we ask
this is God's will he says we have to
accept it thank God we survived
this man tells us we have enough Aid the
coming winter is the problem as the
whole village is sleeping outside
I ask him what it's like to see his
village in this state
ment
I cannot express this for me it's a
catastrophe
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera mulai
Ibrahim in Morocco's Atlas Mountains
well let's try reconnecting to Stephanie
once again she is live in adus and the
Atlas Mountains and Stephanie you were
earlier walking us through the
destruction of just one of the villagers
there
yes we were trying to show you but our
our connection is not working here it is
very remote here because we want to show
you what's happened to people's lives
you have an elderly gentleman we're
trying not to move too much not to lose
the signal again who's just come and sit
and look to at what used to be his life
and I think also we need to remember the
amazing people who live in these
mountains for Generations living off the
mountains living off the land
um I think there's a big question now to
all these remote communities that have
lived there is some tourism in these
areas of course but they live a very
traditional way of life and now
um some of these places they're not
going to rebuild here it's already clear
that this is not going to be possible
people entire Villages entire
communities are going to be moved away
somewhere else but even that is going to
take time and right now the immediate
challenge is what we keep saying but it
is so true is how are you going to clean
this up uh remove the rubble and then
either rebuild or remove the move the
communities to another place it is a
massive undertaking
Stephanie thank you very much for that
that Stephanie Decker joining us live
from ardu's in the Atlas Mountains